so I played Final Fantasy 7 remake and
to put it mildly my mind was blown this
is going to be a must play game of 2020
so sit back for 10 minutes and I'll tell
you why oh and definitely download the
chapter 1 demo right now and see for
yourself what all the fuss is about
[Music]
I'm gonna try my best and not talk about
1997 to final fantasy 7 and that lineage
every time I referenced the og game
you'll hear this sound
let's try it Final Fantasy 7 remake for
new players to the series for context
Square Enix invited me down to play
about 4 hours of the remake and here are
my findings
[Music]
I'm starting with three ways to play the
game they feel largely different fights
in Final Fantasy 7 remake are hectic
multiple enemies and allies on screen at
once all beating 10 bells out of each
other
to counteract the hectic combat a touch
of the X button and time almost
standstill
this is a rest buy this is your
opportunity to take stock of events and
decide on your next move
selecting an attack a potion for health
or maybe some magic all of this with a
knowledge that you won't be punished for
taking your time the slowing down of
time is the intended way to play and it
feels great it really does I can't put
into words how it feels so I'll do it in
the noise instead perfect but what if
you don't want time to be affected then
you my friend are a glutton for
punishment but a Final Fantasy 7 remake
has your back by holding down a shoulder
button it is possible to pull off brutal
moves without freezing the fight making
the entire experience go past at
breakneck speeds
so if adrenaline is pumping through your
veins and you don't want the advantage
of bending time use these shortcuts to
play in real time every time the third
way to play is via the classic version
this is designed to play like the
original game but in reality it doesn't
in the og game everything was to
turn-based I honestly thought this was
going to be the way the game played in
classic mode of the remake but hell no
it doesn't instead it does something
very interesting your character will
automatically attack and block for you
it's strange but hear me out I'm not
saying the game will play itself I'm
saying the AI will only be able to keep
you relatively alive and safe and
slightly knock down an opponent's health
bar the onus is still on you to perform
spells heals and alter tax so in essence
the game tries to be playable like a
traditional JRPG and although that isn't
very successful here what it creates
could be a Stressless way to play the
remake so what's your jam AI assists it
completely real time or slow down time
to get the edge
something you won't see in the demo you
can play right now are the summons and
all my word they are impressive back in
1997 we could use summons which gave us
an epic cutscene followed by a single
strike on the enemy well check it out in
the remake we summon gods who once again
have an epic intro but this time they
actually stick around and fight for a
while they can take aggro away from you
they can beat up the boss in front of
your eyes they are in this world for a
small period of time it's essentially
like having another member in your party
and although they aren't here forever
it's longer than I first expected
sadly summons can't be used all the time
they seem to be just here for your time
of need but that could be just the part
that I played so let's not hold our
breath just there let's take a step back
to the narrative Final Fantasy 7 tells
the story of a seemingly terrorist group
attempting to change the world and free
it of huge corporations who harvest the
earth for MACO
let's not go too deep here but that's
the planets lifeforce if that doesn't
interest you in the slightest while this
may not be the game for you because
Final Fantasy 7 remake is completely
story focused and this version is
doubling down on all interactions
between characters the group we are part
of in Chapter 1 will talk to each other
this can happen off screen - this allows
us to see what their character is like
when cloud isn't around and it
surprisingly adds to their personalities
and we start to care if they live or die
all of these are voiced quite
impressively well while impressively
well for a Final Fantasy game but well
are the same the interactions are so
nuanced it's possible to miss things
completely for example not until the
third time I played the demo did I
notice how Barret all pent up with rage
inside an elevator looks over at cloud
and notices how relaxed he is and tries
to lower his own anger by simply
releasing his best subtle storytelling
and character development in video games
we don't see it very often so that's why
I wanted to highlight it there let's
take this point further in Final Fantasy
7 remake flashbacks and hallucinations
will play a huge part of the
storytelling as we uncover clouds
mysterious past expect to jump around in
time regularly
example in Chapter 1 cloud is asked
about Tifa and boom instantly we are
back to their childhood together tea
Verdi going back into combat for a
moment we can switch between characters
I originally thought this would be
superficial they'd all do generally the
same thing with different animations and
I couldn't have been more wrong
each selectable character is a
completely different build cloud is all
about that buster sword and melee at all
opportunities but there are times when
cloud is useless because the enemies are
too far away to jabber sword into that's
where switching to Barret becomes your
play you know them the mr. T crazy fool
guy with the gun for an arm Barret has
ranged attacks and can shoot down an
opposing cannon in seconds later I was
able to play as Tifa just give me a
moment to look at tifa's amazing
personality stiva is a martial arts
expert and like cloud needs to be up
close and personal to get the full
benefit of most of her attacks what's
truly impressive about Tifa is her
ability to combo and link moves together
I found her the hardest to play with but
without a doubt when mastered she will
be unstoppable Aerith on the other hand
is versed in magic and heals the group
to keep them in battle she seems more
defensive than all the rest and her
summons are a sight to be reckoned with
[Music]
from what I've played Final Fantasy 7
remake is a linear game yeah there's a
few little open-world elements to sniff
out and we'll get into sidequest soon
but the story is linear within the story
are decisions to make they won't change
the overarching story beats but
everywhere in the world are ways to
impact gameplay the first opportunity is
when we set the bomb in chapter 1 30
minutes r20 this directly affects how
long you have to escape the facility
later in chapter 2 we'll meet Aerith and
decide on whether we want to buy a
flower or not yeah okay not mind blowing
I get it
but a little variation goes a long way
the most impressive way I saw a
decision-making shape the game was just
before the boss fight with the air
Buster on the way to the battle you'll
discover these key cards which can be
used to weaken the boss
maybe his mobility car is accidentally
defective and thrown in the trash or his
hardest-hitting rockets are disabled
when fighting that big bugger we want
you to fear the robot moving too quickly
or the air barrage will never actually
hit us changing a boss fight before it
even starts brilliant the boss fights
themselves our long and I mean long
between 10 minutes and about half an
hour on average think of boss battles
like those in Monster Hunter or
blood-borne to really understand the
size and scale and longevity of it all
each battle has phases as the boss is
weakened changing tactics on both sides
a farmer each time the battle amped up
the stakes felt greater fighting for 25
minutes to make one false move and ruin
the entire battle is excruciatingly ly
tense oh and just in case you think
you'll be forced to fight the entire 30
minute section again do not worry my
friend auto-saves happen regularly here
including within each boss fight it's
also possible to save when you see fit
no more hunting down a save point like
in 1997 the modern video
game mechanics
[Music]
another important mechanic in Final
Fantasy 7 remake is the stagger system
it's super simple and super rewarding
under each enemy is an orange bar which
slowly fills during a fight max this out
and they will stagger this opens up a
small window of time where two things
happen one they will not be able to
fight back and to any attacks you learn
now will hit harder and hurt them more
so tactically playing to stagger bosses
before hitting them with your limit
breaker is a tip worth telling the
original Final Fantasy 7 was littered
with great minigames like snowboarding
or motorcycle riding we now know that
they are here in the remake so far we've
seen a keep fit competition in a gym and
more subtly in my playthrough a subtle
timing of a switch with other party
members to open a door we'll have to
wait to see if there are more Minds
blowing our mind numbing minigames in
the final version of the game but they
are here and they will break up gameplay
minigames are great oK we've spoken
about combat way too much let's flesh
things out a little
how about side quests although I haven't
played a side quest thus far we know
they exist
thanks to Final Fantasy sevens Twitter
account which highlights some of the
weird and wonderful things we'll be
doing away from the core story mercenary
quests allow us to take bounties from
everyday NPCs such as clearing a factory
of creatures are searching for a friend
in the slums successfully completing
these missions rewards us with items
which could come in handy later on
that's not the end of side quests they
can happen mid story mission - I'm gonna
call them impact quests during the level
in which I fought the air Buster you
know the one where we weakened it by
taking away some of its powers well get
this all those parts that we took away
were available in another room by using
the door timing minigame we looked at we
can venture completely away from the
core story and pick up these items
before they are disposed of allowing us
to use them in the very same battle I
neglected to say this but I got
absolutely punished by the air Buster so
a protip pick up these items it will
make a huge difference in the fight I
think now's a good time to bring this up
Final Fantasy 7 remake is not easy I'm
sure people will be flexing in the
comments below about how easy they think
it'll be but I
say with confidence you will die at some
point in this game even the smallest and
weakest of grunts can surprise cloud in
large-scale battles breaking his attacks
at the worst possible moment after
almost 20 years of games being
surprisingly easy to play Final Fantasy
7 is taking solace in games like Sakura
and Dark Souls and making a game which
will challenge gamers by no means am I
saying this is a Souls born outing but I
am saying Final Fantasy 7 remake will
challenge you constantly
[Music]
in the original game I know I said I
wouldn't talk about original game but I
am now if you played every encounter
correctly cloud would go on a date with
Barrett now that is a real bromance here
in 2020 the dating system is back we
talked about that flower girl Aerith who
gives you a daffodil thing early in the
game well fast forward to the sewer
fight with ABS ooh and that system is in
full flow after falling into the sewers
we must choose who to speak to first
this then makes clouds relationship with
that character stronger and a little bit
more loving who would you choose to
assist first Aerith our Tifa who's your
girl
it's t4 isn't it it's gotta be Tifa it's
Tifa if you said anything else you're
wrong and finally something you may not
notice straight away but it's such a
good implementation it's all about that
soundtrack it's the same soundtrack as
1997 it's been dragged forward into 2020
and lovingly kept the same I mean the
melody is identical what's great here
though is the new dynamic music system
which sees different versions of the
same track switch now effortlessly to
reflect what's happening on the screen
it's always epic but the entire grandeur
of the audio becomes louder more
profound and prouder and more cinematic
depending on your actions the sombre
music of the slums becomes a crescendo
of orchestral brilliance during a fight
in a livingroom environment this will
bring the whole family in to watch you
slay everything in your path and I can
confirm seven days after playing the
game the music is still stuck in my head
and I'm regularly told to keep quiet
so there we have it twenty-one features
in the final fantasy remake how many
times did I reference the first game
[Music]
and by birds I apologize if this looks
like your kind of game please come back
in the future I'll be covering more
Final Fantasy 7 remake in the weeks to
come before its release I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been an
absolute pleasure and I'll see you next
time
[Music]